they are free you know that so I'm still
free yeah I'm a free I'm playing
yeah good but like I have to give them
lessons to be good
now who's up there I think everyone in
the Villa Squad yeah who's that would
sound the best golfer at the club who's
not being big edit but I am
who's your Challenger who's who's
there's two challenges there's a few
that have tried to get better Ollie
Watkins when I first played with him God
it took about eight hours have you got a
group WhatsApp yeah yeah well it's
called a avfc golfers yeah if you were
to put a message in that WhatsApp group
now saying Lads am I the best what would
come back what you want about Kashi yeah
am I the best they'll be like what are
you on about now like I'm the I'm so if
I were to ask anyway like parallel
universe yeah as I'm on a train back to
London Tyrone Mings is there if I would
just happen I'm really sorry just very
quick question who's your best golfer
yeah you guarantee it yeah